we bring down the banks
this is like bringing down the your
mountaineering partner on the big face
you don't you know you're tied to them
you don't really want to bring them down
because they oh my god i'm tied to them
we're both going down this is what was
happening in 2008. so there needs to be
another part of the plan in place which
simply is a government that understands
that at that point the basket for saving
the finance climber that you have
suddenly clipped their belay and they're
falling the the basket is this you
nationalize them
we nationalized gm in 2008 it worked
they paid us back we saved their ass the
real economy needed saving finance we
paid off we bailed out at 100 cents on
the dollar to the tune of somewhere
between 7 trillion and 13 trillion
dollars i've heard both figures friday
at uci i heard 13 trillion by a very
distinguished economic historian this is
because of quantitative easing as well
as the original bailout
so um that amount of money
is a kind of amazing act but this time
if we've crashed the bank or if they
happen to blow a bubble on their own
either way
we have to at that point say yes we'll
bail you out but now we own you
and so now we own you means the
government is the board of directors
that we begin to set regulations we
begin to determine loans it would be
like the federal credit union all of
these things have their precedence in
earlier public utility district type
moves so at that point with the
government taking over it would run the
loan strategies the repayment rates and
to the extent that it profited the
profits would just go into the treasury
you combine that with the obvious carbon
tax that we need to put on which is not
a tax but is paying the true cost we
need to reconceptualize
and then also the thomas piketty tax
which would be what he suggested two
years ago which is that you don't just
have a progressive tax on
income because people who are wealthy
enough can hide their income in another
country or under the rug or in future
what investments in the future so income
you can hide capital assets a
progressive tax sharply progressive tax
on capital assets is such a game changer
such a paradigm buster that when the
wall street journal and the economist
reviewed piketty's book and they got to
this last chapter they said oh well but
that would never work because and then
their 500 word article ran out and they
got to stop at that point they never
said why because there is no why because
it would work
and it would be an incredibly powerful
tool in terms of the horizontalization
of human wealth
to more of the population there's hardly
a better suggestion and piketty's book
may have been as some people said you
know 11 chapters of marxism followed by
one chapter of keynesian reform
suggestions
but i'm you know i'm a keynesian myself
i think we're in a keynesian world and i
think many people who do the 11 chapters
of marxian analysis would then like to
contribute something useful that could
be done right now in the world and a tax
structure is not the most radical uh
suggestion it's already been done before
so
that would create a government surplus
instead of government being in debt to
finance forever in eternity and
therefore under the thumb of finance
government would be having a surplus
would be in control of finance and it
would have flipped the scissors rock
paper as to who controls who at that
point paper would control gov people
would control governments
governments would control finance
finance would work for the people you
would have the the way the system needed
to work now what would we do with that
money
healthcare of course
free public education of course through
college why not and then also full
employment because full employment is
another gigantic paradigm buster for
capitalism we have 5.4 percent minimum
unemployment if it goes below that the
market's depressed
and you you want labor wage pressure
wage pressure is pressure on human
beings lives and minds in order to keep
them willing to work for depressed wages
so that profits will be better once
again it's going back to that one
algorithm so what you would want at that
point with full employment if you could
always get a good living wage job from
the government then private industries
that existed
which would be on the margin i would
call it would have to compete by giving
a living wage themselves and everybody
would have one along with social
security
so what would everybody do well there
there's no this idea that automation is
going to get rid of jobs is a very silly
bad science fiction story it's not right
it's not going to be that way
many things take the human touch um
taking care of young people taking care
of old people taking care of sick people
and also landscape restoration
um that's the environmental work
uh of of this project of a government
that's in control of of the the human
slash biosphere future because the two
are tied together
would be an enormous amount of
infrastructure changes and uh landscape
restoration in general to get us a
planet where we're not using up you know
the biosphere's regenerative
possibilities by august of every year
which is what we're doing now but are in
balance with the biosphere properly
[Music]
you